[Music]
it's the royal wedding as you've never
seen it on friday the associated press
released digitally restored footage of
the wedding of prince charles and lady
diana the 1981 nuptials remain one of
the most watched events in television
history charles and diana separated in
1992 and divorced in 1996. one year
later the woman known as the people's
princess was killed in a car crash in
paris the 20th anniversary of diana's
death is this thursday jonathan
vigliotti reports on the profound
effects she still has on britain's royal
family
when princess diana stood on the balcony
of buckingham palace then just 20 years
old the world she waved to and the royal
family by her side had no idea what was
to come
and they weren't ready for it they
didn't expect someone like diana to come
along
diana a young english aristocrat was the
picture-perfect princess the buttoned-up
royal family had hoped for but she soon
broke all the rules pr guru mark
burkowski explains
it's very similar to the hollywood movie
system in many ways that they controlled
their iconography their their their
celebrity
um but what they learned very quickly
was the celebrity was bigger than the
studio and i think that's that's a way
to explain it to an american audience
that the studio was was was the royal
family and diana was a bigger star to
the studio
the public can't pick their queen or
king but they did choose diana and
wherever she went the cameras of the
world followed with so much interest
came power we talk about instagram
influencers social media influencers she
was the epitome of that she had a
dialogue with key journalists and she
told the story outside the establishment
machine and when her marriage to prince
charles eventually fell apart her
unprecedented openness about its failure
was both unusual and embraced by the
british public
do you think mrs parker-bowles was a
factor
in the breakdown of your marriage
well there were three of us in this
marriage so it was a bit crowded
diana became a role model for the nation
using her celebrity to change social
norms and to raise awareness for issues
she felt most passionate about
but ultimately even diana couldn't
control her own fame in august 1997
while speeding away from a pack of
paparazzi
her driver later found to be drunk
crashed in a tunnel in paris
the woman who showed it was okay to be
vulnerable couldn't console a
grief-stricken world
it either make or break you
and i wouldn't let it break me
today her legacy lives on with her
children
i wanted it to make me i wanted her to
be proud
of the person i would become i didn't
want her
worried or her legacy to be that you
know
william and or harry
were completely devastated by it and
that all the hard work and all the love
and all the energy that she put into
super younger would go to waste
like their mother prince william and
harry continue to show the royal family
can speak from the heart
for cbs this morning saturday jonathan
vigliotti london
i was just saying we heard some of that
speaking from the heart i know harry has
spoken out about the paparazzi and and
the anger that he had towards them and
what role he may believe they played in
that crash i can't believe it's 20 years
ago i remember that day so well and i
ended up over there you know covering
the aftermath of it in paris um
it and and the world's reaction was you
know i think we were all surprised at
how much you know everyone seemed to be
touched by it i think anyone who lived
during that time it was the wedding
that divorce and then certainly her
death and
memories that will not go away anytime
soon